bring it in bring it in fast fast fast
too close too close little back little
back good good
there the mainstream establishment is
poisoned your mind society we need
answers when the food globalists have
their own Illuminati pyramid what the
Communists get to our trees let's think
about this I'm Jordan Klepper and this
is the opposition
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the way TV should work okay where
was I
it's called mental nationalism and it's
an idea whose time has come
that's right here at the opposition we
believe in our own Golden Rule I mean
you only hear from others what you've
already been telling yourself what is
this protest even about it's about
focusing attention on racial injustice
stop stop please stop I don't want to
talk about that this is football it's
supposed to be simple it's not about
race it's black and white
we'll say things and do things every
night that I haven't said or I haven't
done and create branding with the type
of mentally retarded people that you can
always find ways to trim the fat and to
prove that I fired my camera crew and
produced this segment all by myself
EPA is a public health agency whose sole
mission is to protect our ecology and
Bernie to a clean air clean water
addressing climate
it's according to the faylene new york
times in the last four hundred and
seventy seven days there have been 521
mass shootings in america which is
obviously phony math because how can you
have more shootings than there are days
if that were true we'd be insane not to
do anything about it
rally I'll tell you what they're they're
trying to block the truth we have to
impeach Hillary yeah this is why we need
an informed public who takes action
already got eight signatures repeats
Hillary Clinton take that I saw the
title your book white rage yeah and it
made me furious as far as this Muller
investigation go why why is it taking
why is it taking so long
Muller has some stuff so we know that
you might publicizing information
against like Comedy Central and network
execs I wouldn't sit on that I'd use
that to my benefit gonna show up my
source didn't just say that he called
him a moron he said an effing moron if
truth is a moron that I'm a Laura
because America is full of morons where
logic company central had demanded that
I issue the following Corrections and
retractions Kim Kardashian actually dyed
her hair blonde it was not as I claimed
the result of a very spooky encounter my
apologies to no one more truth tomorrow
good night
[Applause]